PART OF A SCHEDULED ROTATION IN
LESS THAN TWO MONTHS.
NEW AT THIS HOUR, APPROVED
HOMELAND SECURITY DEPARTMENT
REQUEST FOR MORE PERSONNEL AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ABOUT TO MAKE ANOTHER MAJOR
PROPOSAL FOR WHAT CONTINUES TO
BE HIS REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
IT INVOLVES A NEW WAY OF
DECIDING WHO GETS IN AND WHO
DOES NOT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS MORE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE NORTH LAWN.
>> IN ADDITION TO HIS SIGNATURE
ISSUE OF ELIMINATING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, HE IS PROPOSING
MAJOR REFORMS TO LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
SO FAR, THOSE PROPOSALS HAVE
BEEN MET WITH AS MUCH OPPOSITION
AS HIS PLANS TO DEAL WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> WHITE HOUSE STAFF ARE
EXPECTED TO DELIVER A PLAN FOR
MERIT-BASED EMIGRATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTING THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
IRREPARABLY BROKEN PEWS BECAUSE
THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE TEN
TIMES MORE PEOPLE COMING UP WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S LIKE DISNEYLAND.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS PROMOTED
MERIT BASED IMMIGRATION, SIMILAR
TO CANADA, AUSTRALIA, AND
NEW ZEALAND.
HE ALSO WANTS TO ELIMINATE THE
VISA LOTTERY AND A CHAIN
MIGRATION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE FIERCELY OPPOSED
TO THE PRESENT, BUT THE
WHITE HOUSE HOPES THAT MAYBE
CHANGING.
>> WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ALMOND
COMPANY CHILDREN SKYROCKETING.
THE NUMBER OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER, BEING
SMUGGLED AND TAKEN ADVANTAGE IS
HERE TO EXPLOIT IT.
NOW MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HOPEFULLY ARE
SEEING EXACTLY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, AND WE WILL HAVE A NEW
WILLINGNESS TO HELP US ADDRESS
APPEARS >> NANCY PELOSI,
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER, AND
OTHERS WILL BE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TOMORROW FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE JANUARY 9TH
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WALKED OUT
OF THEIR MEETING ON WALL
FUNDING.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE MAIN
TOPIC, BUT IMMIGRATION, NO
DOUBT, WILL COME OF YOUR CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION IS
PREPARING FOR A MASSIVE INFLUX
OF PEOPLE NOW THAT WORD HAS GONE
OUT THAT ATTENTION SETTERS ARE
FULL, AND PEOPLE ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE U.S.
>> YOU WILL BE ALLOWED TO STAY.
YOU WILL BE RELEASED BECAUSE OUR
COURT SYSTEM IS SO BACKLOGGED.
EVEN IF THERE IS NO RIGHT TO
STAY IN THE U.S.
>> TITLING STOMACH TACKLING A
NEW PROBLEM, THEY ARE SENDING
EXPERTS AND HUMAN SMUGGLING TO
THE BORDER.
MIGRANTS POSES CHILDREN TO
CREATE A FAKE FAMILY TO EXPLOIT
AN IMMIGRATION.
THEY ARE FORGING DOCUMENTS TO
PRESENT THEMSELVES AS MINORS
WHEN THEY ARE ACTUALLY 18.
ON ANOTHER FIGHT WITH CONGRESS.
THIS TIME OVER ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR'S THURSDAY
APPEARANCE BEFORE THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
JERROLD NADLER WANT STAFF
ATTORNEYS TO QUESTION HIM ABOUT
THE MUELLER REPORT AFTER MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS HAD HAD THEIR TURN.
>> THERE ARE VALID REASONS TO
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
COUNSEL ASKING QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE SEEN MANY NUMBERS OF
INSTANCES WHERE A WITNESS
FILIBUSTER FOR FOUR AND A HALF,
GIVE A BAD ANSWER, NOT
FOLLOW-UP.
IT'S BECAUSE I FIRED BACK "NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN."
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AGREED TO
APPEAR BEFORE CONGRESS.
THEREFORE, MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
SHOULD BE THE ONES DURING THE
QUESTIONING.
THEY REMIT HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH
MEMBERS ON THEIR QUESTIONS,
REGARDING THE MUELLER REPORT.
>> LATE THIS AFTERNOON, ROD
ROSENSTEIN ANNOUNCED THAT HE
WILL BE LEAVING THE DEPARTMENT
EFFECTIVE MAY 11TH.
BACK IN JANUARY, ROSENSTEIN SAID
THAT HE WOULD BE RESIGNING AFTER
THE MUELLER REPORT WAS RELEASED.
IN HIS RESIGNATION LETTER TODAY,
ROSENSTEIN SAID THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MADE RAPID PROGRESS
IN ACHIEVING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRIORITIES.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR PRAISED
THEM, SAYING HE HAS BEEN AN
INVALUABLE PARTNER TO ME DURING
MY RETURN TO THE DEPARTMENT,
THAT I HAVE RELIED HEAVILY ON